social media has become a powerful tool
for groups like Isis and that can be a
scary thing Isis shows gruesome
beheadings on YouTube recruits on
Twitter and spreads propaganda through
facebook on the heels of the Paris
attacks one question has come up can
technology help beat Isis social media
sites already remove offensive content
youtube says it flags about 100,000
videos each day that violate their terms
of service and Twitter and Facebook say
violent propaganda is against their
policies Facebook told us quote we work
aggressively to ensure that we do not
have terrorists or terror groups using
the site and we also remove any content
that praises or supports terrorism but
there's so much out there on the
internet and even with a hardline policy
security experts say it's hard to stop
Isis's messages they are very savvy when
it comes to marketing to remove their
presence I guess from the internet is
just not possible on a completely fine
grained scale and then there's the
debate over privacy and data Senator
Dianne Feinstein is one leader calling
on technology companies to do more after
the Paris attacks she told MSNBC I think
that Silicon Valley has to take a look
at their products because if you created
product that allows evil monsters to
communicate in this way to be had
children to strike innocence that's a
big problem the FBI and CIA want text
HELP two and one US official said he
would call Zuckerberg to see what
Facebook could do but other than what
the companies have been doing taking
down pages and responding to government
subpoenas and warrants what else can
tech do well they could give government
blanket access to data but this worries
tech experts and privacy advocates who
say you can't open up a so-called
backdoor for the government without
risking other people getting the key to
all we're doing by by theoretically
adding these backdoors is just making it
easier for criminals and other countries
to spy on our on our traffic
in recent years especially after Edward
Snowden's disclosure about NSA spying
Apple and other messaging services like
whatsapp have encrypted user data this
means companies themselves can't access
it even if intelligence agencies make
requests companies from Apple to tumblr
to snapchat have said they will continue
to fight government intrusion and even
if the government says collecting data
could help stop groups like Isis bagels
not sure times of crisis are exactly the
wrong time to reevaluate constitutional
principles we should do it with with
when cooler heads prevail not as
knee-jerk reactions to our tragedy so I
think the system we have in place is
working so what do you think contect do
more to combat Isis without violating
our privacy